You've already taken a look at the profile class, but so
far it doesn't define an entity. What you're going to be doing
now is going in and adding the annotations to make it
an entity. You can look for the places marked to do in
profile.java, it's just a couple things you need to do. You
need to add the annotation to indicate that the class is
an entity, and when you've done that go ahead and write
the annotation here. You also need to add the annotation to indicate
that the user ID is a property that's
going to be used as a unique identifier for profile
entities. When you're done just go ahead and add
the annotation for identifying the unique ID field here.